[Music]
hi
lucy how many years ago
was 50 first dates
17 years ago sounds kind of like you're
making this
up ladies and gentlemen
we are doing a very special
segment for the show um ironically
i'm so inspired by saturday night live
and it's with someone who's one of the
kings of saturday night live
my cinematic soul mate adam sandler
we're going to be shooting a
uh where henry and lucy are at right now
so mr daniel made this
hair concoction
and what did you do to make it mr d
well it's a very short wig from
from charlie's angels actually it's when
i was working at the um
uh what is that the lemonade hot dogs
and hot dogs
and then i also put another color
underneath
and i was like no make sure it looks
white
blonde because i'm so not blonde anymore
so i was going overboard and mr daniel
said no putting depth in it will
actually make it look
more natural
this beautiful woman right here
did 50 first dates together
so
yes i pulled the script out
of my archives you did so what did you
do for lucy
well lucy actually didn't wear a lot of
makeup
she snuck some lashes in there
it wasn't no no makeup but it had lashes
we had
singles so
it was just enough to not have to do
anything else we did a line
literally at the lash line
air kiss um
clinique is the color we use can i look
at it oh my god
there's lucy how did you find that
[Music]
by the way they also like other than
working with little
weird crazy me
like they work with the biggest stars
[Music]
by the way this is why women love this
blonde hair because it's so
good and flattering on your skin but the
maintenance the bleach the damage i'm
just
over it i'm old and set in my ways
after a lifetime of experimenting with
every
cut color and style i'm done
but dammit this really makes me realize
how
amazing blonde hair is
you